around the same time that we were
learning that several antifa far left
extremists for being indebted Enrico
charges we also got this news proud boys
leader Enrique atario ex-probos later
sentenced to 22 years for January 6 Riot
roll and that role was
he was texting people cheering them on
that's it this is freaky man look if you
want to argue with someone incited
someone else to violence like what do
you get for that couple years if that
depending on the seriousness or nature
of the crime Charles Manson for instance
got life for inciting those guys to go f
it up I mean telling people to go murder
himself he just said go f it up and they
took that to mean okay so they went and
then they ended up killing these people
and they're like nope Manson incited it
Manson's going away I don't I don't
trust any of these charges and Rick
atario was not there this is insane
here's the story they say he's been sent
it to 22 years for his in prison for his
role in January 6th he was one of six
proud boy leaders to be charged for
conspiring to stop the certification of
the 2020 election
originally scheduled hearing was
postponed blah blah they went to 33
years he got 22. uh let's uh I wanna
they highlight a few things and also
they gave a whole bunch of other dudes
15 to 20 years
Big's got uh 17. tario was convicted for
obstructing an official proceeding
conspiracy to prevent an officer from
discharging their duties obstruction of
law enforcement during a civil disorder
and destruction of government property
the value over a thousand tario wasn't
at the actual Capital Riot because
they've been arrested days earlier and
he'd been told to leave the city so he
did apparently he went to DC instead
prosecutors say from a hotel outside of
DC tario directed his proud voice to
attack the capital without him Tara's
attorneys have said he wasn't in contact
with any members of the organization
during the riot and pointed to nordian
and Biggs as being the orchestrators of
the riot further they said participating
in a plan for the proud voice to protest
on January 6 is not the same as
directing others on the ground to storm
the capital by any means necessary and
that's the issue
apparently that's it
he wasn't there there was no actual plan
among any of The Proud boys to do
anything they were unarmed many of them
just did dumb things and if you Riot
yeah you're right especially the capital
during the doctoral vote count I think
you're you're gonna you get some serious
charges but like what a year 16 months
maybe for knocking down barricades or
smashing windows I do think it is fair
to say it is personally offensive to
smash the windows of our Capitol
Building you know man I I Look to
American history and all this stuff I
reject and despise the corruption but it
is amazing to go to DC and see all the
all the art and all the history and
people smashing stuff and bashing
windows and trying to break their way in
really really bad I say criminal charges
and we'll be we'll be really harsh real
let's let's be really really harsh a
rider who does this should get 18 months
you look at these guys who uh this guy
burned down a police station in
Minneapolis he gets four years
you look at some of the the what is it
the molotov cocktail uh lawyers where
they get a year
I think 22 years they're ending they're
effectively ending these dudes lives
yeah I mean that's something tario said
today when he spoke he said you know
he's 39 he said please don't take my 40s
from me I would love to get married and
have children and you're going to he's
not going to come out he's like what 60.
uh it's it's sad it's it's sad to see
someone have to be the scapegoat I mean
that's what the US government has done
to him I'm just gonna I'm gonna play the
the time travel game again because I
love this game let's go back to 2017.
and I want you all to imagine going to
one of your friends and telling them in
2023 six proud boys will receive
multi-decade sentences in prison for
what the government describes an act of
domestic Terror to overthrow the seat of
government
and they would laugh harder than
anyone's ever laughed and they'd say
you're a nut job the guys singing in the
in the bar and marching around in polo
shirts and doing what are they saying
like Aladdin or something proud of your
boy or whatever the slogan seriously
you're out of your mind now look where
we are well they're uh God there was one
guy who didn't get charged who was in
the capital that day and that was Sergey
to beat him and he was actually a
Ukrainian azovite soldier who happened
to find himself in the capital that day
and uh some photos were uncovered of him
this week by Laura Loomer and it just I
find it crazy that you have Ukrainian
spies that are in our capital
infiltrating our seat of government and
they're not charged they're allowed to
come to the U.S they're allowed to go
protest in Orlando this week with all
those guys they're allowed to go back to
Ukraine but then we have you know
American citizens that weren't even
there and they're getting 20-year
sentences so this is interesting Laura
Loomer posted this she says I've
exclusively confirmed the FB identified
Ukrainian operatives and neo-nazis we're
at the U.S Capitol on January 6 and even
questioned j6 was about Ukrainian spies
during interviews with the FBI the New
York Times uh actually I'm sorry this is
a Daily Dot not the New York Times uh
said why Ukraine is now being accused of
secretly orchestrating the capital Riot
can I just I want to explain to you what
they do
it's one thing for Laura Loomer to be
like hey look at this dude who is
Ukraine spy who appears to have been at
the Capitol isn't that something crazy
what do they say Ukraine is now being
accused of orchestrating the capital
Riot which is a massive leap from what
Laura Loomer said this is how they try
to debunk The Narrative yeah they create
a conspiracy theory that no one brought
up and then claim it's obviously insane
right
yeah
here's the tweet from Laura Loomer she
says during the private interview with
America Shaman the FBI asked him how he
knew a Ukraine operative who took a
photo with him the day of j6 chansley
didn't know the guy and the FBI
confirmed Ukrainian sir guy how do you
pronounce his name debenham to Benin
something like that there's three y's
that's a lot uh was Ukrainian spy who
was affiliated with the Nazi azov
Battalion this means the U.S Capitol was
penetrated by Ukrainian spies oh I don't
know about spies but at least a spy and
the US government FBI have still not
arrested these people or made the public
aware of the foreign penetration it's an
act of War by Ukraine against the United
States and the US government has sent
200 billion to Ukraine in the last two
years the CIA is funding a color
revolution in the United States via
Ukrainian Nazis and American Nazis who
are being recruited by the CIA etc etc I
do think a lot of this is a bit of a
stretch I think there's a there's a fair
question of this does look like the same
guy are we absolutely sure it is him is
that they said that the FBI and the CIA
asked him about this guy being uh right
so I mean make of make of the you know
extrapolation what you will but the fact
that this guy was in our Capital when
all these other people are being charged
with Insurrection what do you call that
that I mean that is at its core an act
of War if there was China knees spies
doing that what we we know what we would
call that but because it's Ukraine and
Ukraine is good we have to just sit here
and accept it
yeah he just wandered in he was a
tourist there's he couldn't have been
there for any other reason nothing could
be malicious
I mean that's this is the question about
all of January Sixers it's like we know
the FBI had informants from proud boys
or Earth keepers of different groups we
know that they had people on the ground
that day we know that the mayor of DC
and Nancy Pelosi were offered to have
additional security and support of the
capital and that was turned down so if
the government intelligence communities
knew this could potentially happen and
it was such a big deal why didn't they
stop it why did they let it happen uh it
for me that's just evidence that it
wasn't I mean my one of my favorite
lines from the opening statements for
the proud boys trial was uh one of their
lawyers can't remember who at this
moment said you know she was reading
these texts where these guys are saying
so what time should we meet up in the
morning where where are you going to be
like they they didn't have a plan and
she just said this group couldn't
organize a group order at McDonald's
like they did not plan an Insurrection
they did not try to overthrow the US
government but I think ultimately that's
the narrative that you know our
intelligence Community really needed to
be the case that's why they didn't
intervene with theoretically they should
have if they knew it was was going to
happen I do think things are going to
get a lot crazier in 2024. I think it'll
be more heavy-handed on on the side of
the left seeing these uh these far
leftists be criminally charged with
domestic Terror Enrico good interesting
they're criminals who stormed a
government facility and firebombed
buildings houses shut of Cups yeah they
need to be locked up the rider is in
front of a January 6 who are smashing
things and trying to break their win
yeah they should be criminally charged
too but that's what 16 months for
violent Riot attacking cops not 20 years
the heavy-handedness is fairly obvious
the fact that Enrique tario according to
defense they said he wasn't even in
contact with them that day they gave him
22 years you know I'll tell you what's
really interesting about this is that
apparently there was a statement
released by uh uh tario gave a statement
to the judge saying he regretted his
actions do you see this
and that um you know he was remorseful
and he shouldn't have done it and he
said that he's not a political Zealot he
didn't even know that you could over you
could change the results of an election
and that you know he shouldn't have
compared people to founding fathers or
anything like that
I think and then the judge apparently
said he doesn't see any reason why
Enrique would be remorseful of his
actions or actually believe it look man
it's gonna get crazier in 2024 it will
get crazier we're already seeing a whole
bunch of videos of people having their
homes rated by feds now in 2023 two and
a half years later
there's how many people were there at
the Capitol we know that people who
wandered in Clueless you know a few
hours after the start of everything were
criminally charged and sentenced to a
year or more we know that the people who
are storming the front actually get
engaged in violence have been criminal
charged criminally charged but there are
hundreds more maybe even a thousand more
who have not yet been charged who were
there and we're starting to see these
videos pop up
it seems that they waited until the
start of the election cycle Joe Biden
just announced I guess what he's doing a
25 million dollar ad buy for the next
campaign around the exact same time the
feds are starting to raid more people
for January 6. and don't you forget it
there were a lot of media personalities
social media figures who were cheering
on what was going on outside of what
Enrique tario did if they're claiming
I'll tell you this you guys if they're
claiming Enrique tario was was
organizing and inciting and encouraging
it so that he gets 22 years think about
what's going to happen to the people who
are on these alternative social media
platforms with thousands of viewers and
they were saying more more
do you think that the feds are going to
ignore that
no I think next they're going to come
for media personalities we know that
James O'Keefe is being investigated in
New York not necessarily related to
January 6 but I think a large component
of what they're doing is going to be
the people on social media encouraging
it calling for more and cheering people
on they're going to say we're part of a
criminal conspiracy and they were they
were inciting and they knew what they
were doing Etc yeah
this case is
precedent setting I mean so uh judge
Kelly who was was overseeing this trial
said that he said this in all of the
sentencings but today he was
specifically saying our country needs a
peaceful transfer of power and you broke
our tradition of the peaceful transfer
of power and so he's basically saying
these are the people that ruin democracy
which seems bizarre to me because it
seems obvious that they did not actually
have a plan to do anything yes they were
going to Rally yes they were in DC yes
things got out of hand they might need
to face some charges but the idea that
it was a conspiracy seems weak anyways
and in fact we have had peaceful
transfer transfers of power since right
we had midterms elections nobody right
at the Capitol when Congress was sworn
in for the newest term like
it seems actually fine you want it to be
that there is more tension that's that
that's my editorial take on it that
there is a desire for there to be
contention between uh different
political factions and the only solution
is we have to lock some of you up right
I mean like I've been saying if your
politicians can only campaign on vote
for me and I will go after your enemies
then that just continues the escalation
by the way is what I think Biden can
only campaign on because we're about to
have student loan debt repayments he
couldn't get those wiped away we're
about to have I mean inflation is not
great we have tons of Millennials who
are saying I would love to buy a home
and I cannot Biden is not
um a healthy person he is polls
consistently show people think he is too
old to run again he is the oldest
sitting president in our nation's
history I think he is actually very weak
going into this campaign and that's why
magically this timing all lines up where
Trump Trump's indictment the proud boy
results I mean all of this is happening
at once I got my bribe from the uh Biden
Administration over the weekend I got a
letter it says they forgave seven
thousand dollars of student loan debt I
didn't ask I didn't sign up for it I
didn't want it and they did it anyway
because it had been 21 years the debt's
older than 20 years so they just wiped
it off and just such a bribe I mean it's
just disgusting I thought there was
programs like that that have existed for
a while for like a decade at least
there's been programs to help people who
are lower income or whatever those
circumstances may be to help with
student loans so that's like I know
that's been a big point of contention
with people who are now uh finding fault
with Biden's plan because they're like
there's programs to help us they already
exist we're already doing handouts just
once the feather in his cap he wants to
say I'm the president that did this yeah
yes who wants the bribe thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time